every once in a while you come across a
data point that makes you stop and think
more critically about what's going on in
the bitcoin market as we now know in the
month of june there was more bitcoin
taken off of exchanges than ever before
in the history of the asset the reason
why this is important is because one
people are learning about not your keys
not your coins one of the advantages of
bitcoin is that it provides for
self-sovereignty you can actually hold
the bitcoin and you don't have to rely
on a third-party custodian and so as
more people have gotten to understand
the power of self-sovereignty and they
take that bitcoin off of exchanges it's
showing that people are waking up and
they're realizing the true value of a
decentralized digital currency with a
private key component the second thing
is that there was plenty of contagion in
the market over the last couple of weeks
we saw failures of various projects and
the various companies as well and so
whenever fear and uncertainty and chaos
are high people get nervous and they
want to take possession of their assets
if you combine the increased education
around not your keys not your coin with
the fear uncertainty doubt and chaos in
the market you can see exactly why more
people took bitcoin off of exchanges
than ever before in the history of
bitcoin now of course when that bitcoin
flows off of exchanges it means that
bitcoin in the circulating supply is
becoming more and more illiquid people
don't have their bitcoin simply sitting
on an exchange and at the press of a
button have the ability to sell it it
doesn't mean people can't take their
bitcoin out of self-custody and bring it
back onto the exchange just means that
there's more friction for them to do
that
in the past as we see bitcoin become
more and more illiquid it usually has
led to further price increases in the
near to medium term
nobody knows what's going to happen but
seeing more people take self-custody of
their assets is a good thing
it means that more folks are actually
getting the true value proposition of
the decentralized digital currency
it's awesome to see so many bitcoin
coming off of exchanges bitcoins
becoming more illiquid and people are
becoming more empowered as the asset
continues to mature and reach mainstream
adoption
there will never be a moment in history
where 100 of all bitcoin in circulation
is not on an exchange that would be too
insane but i do think that over time
we're gonna continue to see more and
more people taking bitcoin off of
exchange it and maybe later this year or
maybe not we may see more bitcoin taken
off of exchanges than what we saw in
june
time will tell
learn about self-custody
learn about the advantages of
self-sovereignty because bitcoin affords
you that opportunity today if you don't
go ahead and capitalize on it you're not
getting the true value of bitcoin you're
not getting everything it has to offer
you
learn about self-custody and learn about
self-sovereignty your future self will
likely thank you